[Music]
the soft reboot that was Assassin's
Creed origins introduced a new approach
to the series's brand of stealth action
gameplay along with an expansive and
vibrant open world with many dynamic
systems at work in this year's follow up
Assassin's Creed Odyssey developer
Ubisoft Quebec built upon the pillars of
its predecessor and in the process shows
greater confidence in the series's new
direction taking on the role of either
Alexios or cassandra siblings and former
Spartans turned mercenaries you'll
quickly become involved in the larger
conflict of the Peloponnesian War in 431
BCE the amount of detail packed into
each location across the Greek mainland
and the islands of the Mediterranean Sea
is impressive tied together by a dynamic
ecosystem where local wildlife and
civilians keep their territory but as
you dive further you'll see the many
hardships and realities of life in
ancient Greece firsthand including the
horrors of slavery and they ever-present
war between the military driven Spartans
and the bureaucratic Athenian army I
could make use of a canary we need to
weaken their position if we are protect
to the field and drive them back to
Athens featuring a map that's more than
double the size of the previous game
Odyssey is built to be explored and as
incidental content to reward your
curiosity you get the sense that your
actions will have a lasting impact
wherever you go and Odyssey offers up a
wealth of content that fuels your growth
at a steady pace though the issue of
level gating comes up occasionally
preventing you from actively exploring
any region you wish you can take a break
from the main story and dive into the
breadth of side content and your leisure
as you traverse deeper into the world
some of Odysseys more involved missions
make themselves known in one of the more
exciting quests you'll encounter several
mythological beasts hidden within the
world offering up some of the game's
most memorable encounters where brute
force isn't always the answer
one of Odysseys more clever features is
the exploration mode with this optional
mode enabled you're challenged to use
your observation and deduction skills to
find your next target without the
support of icons or waypoints
exploration mode heightens the pride
that comes from solving puzzles and this
makes each step of your adventure feel
all the more rewarding I have my money
Markos
I'd hate to have to sell our vineyard of
course he will
Oh after there's another matter I want
to discuss with you after fine but I'm
taking a horse it's too hot too long a
walk to go on foot but think of it as
interest Marcus
everybody benefits the both Cassandra
and Alexia share the same story beats
there are differing personalities and
points of view offer unique flavor with
some scenes in questlines feeling more
appropriate with a particular character
even during their challenging
circumstances they'll still break the
tension with humor or sarcasm it's even
possible to romance side characters and
Odyssey I'm going to make you an elixir
that will give you the vigor of a man a
fraction of your AIDS while some of
these scenes can be amusing
they're often just bizarre shows of
affection that leave no lasting impact
allow me to satisfy your hunger I've
never been with a mercenary before very
well let's see what you're made of
[Music]
these awkward romance options also
appear after ordering otherwise serious
events which cheapen some of the moments
in the story but with nine possible
endings at the main story's conclusion
and the potential for characters that
die before their story is completed
there's a surprisingly large amount of
cause and effect that can make the
narrative feel all your own
in regards to its combat Odyssey no
longer features the shield's introduced
in origins and as a result action flows
at a brisker pace by placing the
emphasis more on dodging and pairing
incoming flows from enemies fighting
feels more involved in dynamic you also
have the ability to build your character
with stealth long-range and melee
specialties and respect those abilities
and anytime giving you the flexibility
to customize your play style this has
been maybe
Odyssey also brings the return of naval
combat and sailing gameplay seafaring
offers up some of the most exciting and
visually pleasing moments at the game
such as finding lost sunken ruins in the
ocean's depths we're facing off against
increasingly aggressive rival ships the
scope of Odyssey is enormous and for the
most part it's presented well but some
of the new innovations feel a bit lost
in the grand scheme of the game with
conquest battles you can pick a side in
the ongoing war between the Spartan and
Athenian armies dismantling the rivals
influence in a region while this is a
solid way of gaining resources and
improving your standing with the faction
the implementation into Odysseys general
systems make it feel mostly half-baked
the game's mechanics don't seem to take
it seriously either this is most
apparent when the main story has you
helping a particular faction despite the
site content in the area negatively
impacting them in some regard when
looking at Odyssey in the bigger picture
it can often feel like there's too much
game for its own good this is further
exacerbated by the expansive map which
can be a chore to travel through there
are also some notable bugs and hitches
that crop up throughout including those
that prevent progress and missions to
outright crashing the game several times
throughout my journey progression felt
somewhat exhausting which made some of
the more impactful and exciting moments
in the story feel like a drag despite
this the ambition within Assassin's
Creed Odyssey is admirable which is
reflected in its rich attention to
detail for the era and its approach to
handling the multi-faceted narrative
with strong protagonists at the lead
while its large-scale campaign can
occasionally be tiresome Odyssey makes
great strides in its massive and dynamic
world and the joy to venture out and
leave your mark on its ever-changing
setting
[Music]